so i am pretty new to this whole show
hosting thing so i've been checking out
other hosts to see how they do it so i
can steal ideas from them blatantly one
of the hosts
one of the hosts that was kind enough to
let me do this was rachel maddow of
msnbc we sat down in our office in new
york let's watch it because we filmed it
hey everybody it's me peter and i'm
sitting with one of my favorite cable
news cast people people new sure one of
my favorite hosts of all time and it's
rachel maddow and i'm so thrilled you're
here thanks i'm a new host what advice
would you have for me going into in into
the into the grind of four days a week
if four days a week because we're doing
four days a week yeah can i have your
job yeah five days a week is harder than
four days a week i bet yeah um so uh the
advice i would give you is just ask me i
did
i felt obsessed
it was kind of old-timey it's like
sounds like five would be one day hotter
old fella wouldn't nickel
make sure that
you uh
make a complete list of all the good
friends and people you trust in the
world right now because all of a sudden
people who you don't remember being
friends with will claim that they've
been friends with you forever because
now you're on tv interesting yes as
eminem said all of a sudden i have some
five million cousins
keep it real him
you're happy oh i'm happy yeah i know
i'm happy you can tell you're happy oh
thank you yeah you feel it yeah well you
just seem like people i think you you
seem like a guy who has something to
offer and people who are unhappy don't
necessarily have that well yeah it's
either giving or taking right some
people you're talking to them and you
can kind of feel something being sucked
out of you and then that when two people
that have something to give get together
i think you do bounce the light around
you ping it in your pawn you bounce the
light around yeah we'll be right back
you're tall for a lady you're 5 11. and
and i'm tall for a fella
tall especially tall for a lady i'm
abnormally large for a woman my
girlfriend is the normal height of a
girl she's the average she's shorter
than me she's shorter than me she's i'm
five eleven she's like five five or so i
don't she wears heels but the here's the
smart thing about our functional lesbian
relationship is that she's allowed to
choose the height of the furniture so
all of our couches and chairs are very
low to the ground and it's sort of like
you kind of approach as a tall person
and go whoa i'm going that way
but that appropriate size furniture is
part of a flr
fl functioning lesbian relationship
called a flirt a flurry yeah i've had a
lot of flurries in my time i love it but
men are our shells of people and we're
afraid and height is one of those things
as a tall person i'm glad i don't have
to worry about that but height jawline
hairline age and then of course the
equipment i know very little about male
genitalia you're not missing much really
it's i think it's overrated i kind of
have a theory that everyone's just
faking like ooh look at that
yeah gay men and straight away pretend
like this is important right it's just
like it's like wine you just give value
to it like oh it's a fine one that's a
great penis
what are you basing that on the age the
barrel
talking dicks we'll be right back
i keep my hair a certain length so i can
pretend to be a cop i'm not joking we
have similar hair you could also be a
police officer what this is cop hair
this is like destructive hair though you
oh you're called in after i you tell me
to beat it
you come in with those glasses and
you're like scram this is my
jurisdiction and i'm like ah maddow
even a good cop name
that's something you could teach me
i'm a host and you have gravitas and i'm
a goof
i don't think i have gravitas you have
more no you're a very funny lady and
incredibly talented but you you can when
needed
focus it up and do the news there's a
thing that happens in cable news which
is that we make fun of the breaking news
trope like let's call this breaking news
even though it obviously isn't right and
i'm unwilling to do that because we do
actually have the responsibility to
sometimes convey that something
important is going on sure we're live on
tv if something is important you work we
are going to stay on tv somebody has you
a piece of paper yeah could you read
like a very silly uh uh
like news story that we wrote you but
read it seriously
this just in and someone hands us this
just in um
several kittens were found in a a barrel
of cotton candy
uh their names were bing bong
ding dong
sorry and clumpy butterfly
though uh clumpy went wee-wee on
bing-bong
up next
up next a dog with two butts
have you ever done mushrooms
no
you should do mushrooms really oh why
it's not really a drug it's an awakening
it's really good
i like this the throat last question
mushrooms yeah
this was truly a delight oh thanks
oh
are you not a hugger no i'm a hugger now
yeah
people who do mushrooms are huggers